congratulations to all newly elected
msps obviously commiserations to those
who've lost out i know from
experience in the past how tough that is
but to everybody who's been
elected congratulations it's a huge
honour to
be a member of our national parliament
but you know while i'm delighted about
all of the
snp msps elected i am thrilled beyond
words
to see kokab stewart elected it has
taken
us far too long more than 20 years but
today she becomes
the first woman of colour to be elected
to our national parliament so party
politics aside
this is a really special and a very
significant moment for scotland and i
could not be prouder right now you said
you're delighted to see a new college
yourself to have co-cab in your team but
it does look like you're maybe just
going to fall short of that majority
people have spoken of what do you make
of
the results like you know it's not a
huge surprise i've said all along a
majority was a long shot we have a pr
system in hollywood it's not meant to
deliver
majorities but i'm thrilled with our
results
we'll see the final tally of seats later
on this evening
but already we know that we've won more
constituency seats than we did
at the last election we've won a higher
share of the vote
in the constituency ballot than in 2016
and actually we've won
more votes and a higher share of the
vote than any party
in the history of devolution by any
standards
this is a historic achievement a quite
extraordinary achievement for
the snp our vote share is up the vote
share of the other main parties
is down so the snp has won this election
emphatically the message we took to the
people of scotland has been endorsed
and i now intend to get back to work to
deliver on all
of what we put before the scottish
people delivering in all those things
will it be
more difficult being a minority
government again and also you hope to
have a referendum in the first half of
the next parliament
is that a realistic noun yes i mean i've
said and i meant it that
covered getting through the kobe crisis
has to come first and that is what
i will deliver i'll be getting back to
work tomorrow to take the decisions
to continue to steer us through the
covert crisis but
you know the while we don't know the
final tally of seats right now it looks
as if it is beyond
any doubt that there will be a
pro-independence majority
in that scottish parliament and by any
normal standard of democracy
at that majority should have the
commitments
it made to the people of scotland
honoured so for any westminster
politician who tries to stand in the way
of that
i would say two things firstly you're
not picking a fight with the snp
you're picking a fight with the
democratic wishes of the scottish people
and secondly
you will not succeed the only people who
can decide the future of scotland
are the scottish people and no
westminster politician
can or should stand in the way of that
and how quickly do you start making
those demands to westminster
westminster knows my view on these
things the timing of an independence
referendum
now should be a matter for the scottish
parliament it should be for the judgment
of the parliament to consider
the position with covid and when the
parliament considers that the time is
right to have that requirement and that
is not a decision
for boris johnson or for any westminster
politician
and of course my immediate job is to get
almost dealing us through
that crisis but then it is for the
people of scotland to decide their own
future and that is not a demand for me
or the snp that is what the people of
scotland have voted for you know in
normal uh democratic debate parties that
promise something in an election and get
elected
are meant to deliver on those
commitments it's an absurdity
that in scotland we seem to have other
parties determined to block
the party or parties that have won the
mandate for something
from delivering that but the people of
scotland of course are sovereign
the people of scotland should choose
their own future and whether or not
scotland chooses independence is
entirely up to
the majority here in scotland so is that
a section 30 requests to get those
powers so that you can decide well
it's it's for when the scottish
parliament when it decides is
right to make the preparations for an
independence referendum
if boris johnson or whoever is prime
minister at the time
has any respect for scottish democracy
they will come together with the
scottish government as happened in the
run-up to 2014
and agree that transfer of power and if
they refuse to do that then they will
have to take the decision
to legally challenge the ability of the
scottish parliament to deliver on what
the people of scotland voted for and the
absurdity and outrageous nature of that
a westminster government potentially
going to court to
overturn scottish democracy i can't
think of a more powerful argument for
scottish independence than that one
thank you